Mesdames et Messieurs mes respectueuses
salutations je viens de vous dire
bonsoir
je ne suis qu'une résonance de l'Afrique
et les mots sont les sens de l'art que
je pratique je m'en faisant avec eux ils
sont devenus des amis alors je me
présente à ceux et celles qui croisent
ma route à tous et à toutes je m'appelle
ami et je fais ami ami avec les mots
avec eux j'essaie de mettre de
l'ambiance autrement qu'avec du coupé
décalé muni de mes couplets déclamés je
fais plein de sang caler je rééquilibre
les méninges histoire de ressusciter un
petit peu nos sagacités et avec mes mots
rallye et bien moi je fais mon bouquin
outrance dans la cité en tant que
prêtresse qui essaie d'exorciser le
monde de ces mots Emmaüs avec des mots m
o t S et l'exercice de cette mission me
mène ici en tant que porteuse de parole
par excellence afin d'apporter ma
tranche d'expérience cette expérience
qui est une somme d'influence et qui
aujourd'hui tente de produire aussi
pourquoi pas de l'influence
après une maîtrise en droit des affaires
et une admissibilité en fiscalité des
entreprises après neuf années en
entreprise dans l'audiovisuel je me
retrouve là artiste
pluridisciplinaire en auto-production
je touche au dessin à la danse à la
peinture aux champs je joue des
instruments mais essentiellement
slameuse et donc amener malgré moi à
avoir un impact sur l'environnement et
c'est connu de tous depuis toujours
l'art a toujours eu un lien très étroit
avec l'influence
mais puisque tout dans la vie commence
par un commencement un début une
naissance et bien par le pouvoir de la
mémoire nous allons remonter le plus
loin possible et nous allons poser les
bagages en enfance
et j'aimerais profiter de l'occasion
pour vous demander la permission de
faire un petit sondage par le principe
de la main levée est-ce que parmi vous
certains ont certaines ont des souvenirs
de leur enfance datant de on va dire
entre 10 ans et moi
et bien c'est pas mal ça
ensuite
quels sont ceux et celles qui ont des
souvenirs entre 7 ans et moi
ça serait réduit on va corser un petit
peu les choses quels sont ceux et celles
qui ont des souvenirs on va dire à
partir de deux ans et demi et moins
j'avoue c'est très compliqué et j'ai vu
une main se lever là et madame je pense
que vous faites partie de ceux et celles
qu'on appelle les mémoires d'éléphant en
espérant que vous n'êtes pas rancunière
voilà c'est la petite parenthèse moi je
suis partie aussi de la dernière tranche
donc j'ai des souvenirs datant environ
de mes deux ans deux ans et demi et le
plus vieux souvenirs que j'ai c'est moi
en train de courir dans les rues de
du camp commando de Bouaké là où je suis
né en train d'essayer de faire tournoyer
vous savez ces espèces de jeux que nous
avions d'enfance fait de papiers des
hélices on jouait à l'avion
et moi mon avion il était particulier
parce que mon père avait pris son temps
pour fabriquer ce pavillon mon père
excellait dans la manipulation de tout
ce qu'il avait autour de lui c'était
enfin qu'on est sûr de la fabrication il
fabriquait des avions avec des morceaux
de carton avec des bobines qui
l'essayait de faire tournoyer
il fabriquait également des couveuses
qui permettaient de faire éclore tous
ses œufs que les poules abandonnées
et mon père il aimait tellement bricoler
qu'il y avait une pièce spéciale à la
maison qui était en débarras où il y
avait absolument tout et l'autre chose
qui me revient tout de suite en tête
c'est cet objet bleu qui était mon
cadeau pendant une fête de Noël
un cadeau qui a suscité on va dire le
désaccord de ma mère parce que elle
estimait que ce cadeau là ne
correspondait pas à mon genre
le genre féminin et pour cause mon père
m'avait offert une voiture télécommandée
vous imaginez dans les années 90 une
jeune fille une petite fille qui a une
voiture télécommandée et puis à cet
instant j'ai compris que je ne ferai pas
partie des filles à poupée je préférais
les voitures télécommandées parce que
c'était le symbole de l'action des
années plus tard j'ai fini par
comprendre que cette action avait
produit quelque chose en moi
la leçon que j'aimerais tirer c'est que
je ne ferai pas partie de ces personnes
qu'on met dans des cases
un autre souvenir me vient en tête
toujours dans cette pièce qui sert de
débarras la guitare cassée de mon père
qui était le symbole de sa passion pour
la musique
qu'il a dû abandonner c'est la raison
pour laquelle elle est restée cassée
aussi longtemps il avait aussi en
passion en commun cette passion avec ma
mère qui elle c'était une grande
mélomane de musique elle achetait les
Alpes m'écouter la musique à nos points
finir et concernant ma mère il y a
d'autres souvenirs aussi qui me
reviennent toujours dans la période de
la petite enfance
c'était celle qui s'assurait à ce qu'on
ne s'écarte pas de la route parce que ma
mère malheureusement après son
probatoire qu'elle a malheureusement
échoué elle n'a pas eu l'opportunité
d'aller plus loin alors que ma mère
rêvait d'être avocate et donc étant à la
maison et c'est assuré que mes frères au
moins on allait poursuivre ce rêve donc
elle insistait elle était mon maître de
maison je fais exprès de ne pas dire
maîtresse ma mère était mon maître de
maison parce qu'elle avait cette manière
de transmettre tellement assidue et
patiente qu'elle pouvait même prendre la
place dans l'enseignant et ma mère a
rodé mon éducation et c'est assuré que
je puisse retenir toutes mes leçons elle
savait que j'avais déjà un petit des
petites prédisposition avec la mémoire
et donc elle s'est assurée à rôder ça et
aujourd'hui la mémoire me sert dans mon
travail
elle avait également un autre moyen pour
nous transmettre l'amour de ce qu'elle
avait de ce qu'elle savait
des récits et c'est par les récits que
ma mère m'a transmis l'amour des lettres
l'amour du conte des histoires et elle
avait en commun aussi le récit avec mon
père alors c'était une des méthodes
qu'ils utilisaient quand mes frères et
moi on avait un petit peu de relâchement
au cours des études il y avait la
méthode forte que vous connaissez donc
la chicote et puis il y avait la méthode
douce donc c'était de raconter une
partie de leur enfance
et ses récits consistaient à nous faire
comprendre des messages essentiels
il racontait là toute la difficulté
qu'ils avaient pour se rendre à l'école
de fois parfois de voir se contenter
dans ce stylo toute l'année et quand on
entendait ces histoires là mes frères et
moi tout de suite on se sentait
privilégié d'avoir toutes ces
fournitures là et donc on se remettait
tout de suite au travail peu importe
l'heure peu importe le jour et ça c'est
un moyen de nous emmener sur le droit
chemin
l'urlité de créativité
résilience
discipline
ne pas se mettre dans des cases
et un autre souvenir qui me vient aussi
en tête cette fois-ci à 7 ans c'est
devant la télévision à peine à un maître
et demi prête même à Bondy à l'intérieur
est-ce que je voyais si tu as un clip
et aller voir dans les années 90 on
n'avait pas droit à la télévision on
continue comme vous savez
c'était seulement les samedis et les
dimanches et ce jour-là c'est un samedi
et on avait droit à des sélections
musicales internationales donc qui nous
permettait de voyager sans avoir à
prendre de billets d'avion ou à bouger
son corps et il y avait ce monsieur là
la voix suave qui chantait et qui
traversait les mots d'une chose que
j'aimais particulièrement qui était
tantôt en Amérique tantôt en Europe
tantôt en Afrique il était vêtu de noir
et de blanc et j'ai fini par comprendre
plus tard que le titre de sa chanson
faisait référence à ces deux couleurs
enfin c'est deux temps black or white
et je pense que vous avez plus ou moins
deviné de quel artiste il s'agit celui
que j'appelle affectueusement le plus
ivoirien de tous les Américains c'est
pas juste pour la rime parce qu'il y a
une histoire derrière en fait Michael
Jackson est venu en Côte d'Ivoire après
avoir effectué un test ADN selon mes
recherches qui avaient donné comme
résultat des origines de Côte d'Ivoire
dans peuple qui se situe actuellement
dans l'actuel kranjabo c'est la raison
pour laquelle Michael Jackson est parti
à kranjabou donc
mesdames et messieurs Michael Jackson
est en ivoirien et a donc longtemps que
la Côte d'Ivoire a de l'influence
la petite parenthèse
et donc Michael Jackson qui a eu un
impact retentissant je pense que la
plupart des personnes dans l'assemblée
savent un petit peu son parcours
un impact gigantesque dans l'industrie
de la musique du divertissement et moi
quand je regardais la télévision la
seule chose que je me suis dit à
l'instant c'est que quand je serai
grande je vais faire comme lui
Michael Jackson qui a impacté toutes ses
générations
qui aujourd'hui
font des prestations on rappelle en
souvenir et qui ont même des codes
qu'il a instauré et dans cette vague de
nouvelle génération il y a eu cet
artiste aussi qui m'a servi de repère
d'ailleurs c'est le dernier souvenir qui
me vient en tête on va dire c'est
l'achat de mon de ma première cassette
mon premier album intitulé souvent
c'était le groupe Destiny's Child et
dedans j'avais ma préférée je pense que
vous avez plus ou moins une idée de qui
c'est Beyoncé
et je rêvais d'être Beyoncé parce que
Michael Jackson c'était un homme et donc
Beyoncé c'était plus facile pour moi
parce que c'était une figure féminine
donc il y avait le même impact et du
coup je décide que moi aussi je serai
Beyoncé
je finis par participer à une
compétition que je remporte en catégorie
RnB et je me rends compte que je ne
pourrai pas être Beyoncé parce que
Beyoncé est déjà occupé
et que finalement si je voulais moi
aussi faire comme Michael Jackson parce
que la phrase que je m'étais dit c'était
d'avoir cette influence là sur les gens
il fallait que je sois moi-même et la
meilleure version de moi-même chaque
jour qui passe et donc je continue ma
route et je rencontre en chemin des
personnes qui me rappellent tout ce que
j'étais capable de faire notamment mes
écrits il me disent ce serait bien que
tu fasses du slam parce que ce serait
davantage intéressant de t'entendre dire
tes messages
et donc je me rends à cet atelier
decriture en tant que chanteuse et vu
que j'avais une j'avais un examen je
n'ai pas pu chanter et donc j'ai eu ma
première scène slam le 22 janvier 2010
à cet instant là à cette époque là il y
avait pas de slameuse il y avait des
slameurs certes mais c'était des
Français
et je continue le chemin je finis par
revoir kajim parce que c'est grâce à
kajim que j'ai participé à cet allié
atelier d'écriture qui me demande de
participer à une compétition alors je
déteste les compétitions parce que je
suis une mauvaise perdante mais je me
soigne je vous promets que je me soigne
et je participe à cette compétition je
suis retenu parmi les 10 meilleurs
slamers de Côte d'Ivoire
après la compétition on se rend compte
que nous avons une passion mais aucun
public
on décide alors de faire la promotion du
slam
et c'est donc en 2014 que l'association
collective au nom du slam n'est
officiellement et inscrit dans les
registres de Côte d'Ivoire mais du
gouvernement de Côte d'Ivoire
et ce collectif a décidé de passer par
plusieurs canaux pour faire la diffusion
du slam donc les scènes libres
mensuelles et la première scène a eu
lieu à 13 villes je me rappelle il y
avait que deux personnes dans le public
on était 10 lameur sur la scène et avec
deux personnes donc vous imaginez un peu
le parcours qu'on a dû faire jusqu'à
présent parfois il nous fallait faire
des performances pendant que les
télévisions étaient allumés à côté avec
un match de foot qui passait
mais on n'a pas abandonné
et tout était dans le nom de notre
collectif au nom du slam on allait
continuer on allait continuer jusqu'à ce
qu'on puisse atteindre notre objectif
et finalement on rencontre des personnes
en chemin des institutions qui nous
donnent on va dire ça cette petite lueur
d'espoir c'était pas énorme mais on a
continué et on a commencé à initier des
spectacles à thèmes où on m'élève du
slam avec un petit peu de théâtre donc
on a appelé des pièces islamiques
c'était une grande première dans le
monde du slam et en Côte d'Ivoire
ensuite on a créé le championnat
national de slam qui fait naître des
Champions et des championnes qui vont
nous représenter à la Coupe du Monde il
y a deux Coupes du monde et à la Coupe
d'Afrique et toutes les fois où la Côte
d'Ivoire a participé on a été parmi les
six premiers
ensuite on va créer le festival
international babislam qui est donc
cette fête de mots afin de montrer aux
gens que le slam c'est pas seulement
grand corps malade mais c'est une
pluralité de personnes et donc on invite
aussi tous ces slameurs avec lesquels
nous étions en contact grâce au réseau
sociaux pour montrer que nous aussi on
peut effacer la notion de frontière
après ça on initie le championnat
intercolaire d'Islam donc la coupe en
terre scolaire d'Islam pour pouvoir
transmettre au plus jeune parce qu'on
s'est dit quand on lançait le mouvement
que pour ne pas que ce soit juste en
effet de mode il fallait transmettre en
continu et passer par toutes les forces
de la jeunesse et même des adultes on
pouvait atteindre
cet objectif là donc continuellement
faire de nouveaux slameurs
et durant tout ce parcours tous les
éléments que mon père et ma mère m'ont
transmis nous ont toujours accompagnés
soit individuellement soit en collectif
et aujourd'hui nous sommes heureux de
voir que sur le terrain il y a des
jeunes qui nous écrivent pour nous dire
aujourd'hui je viens à la scène grâce à
toi ou grâce à d'autres slamers
Ivoiriens ce n'est plus grands corps
malade ou encore Abdel Malik comprend
pour référence mais l'islamers Ivoiriens
africains nous sommes heureux de
constater que aujourd'hui nous avons
réussi à faire en sorte que le slam
puisse s'inscrire dans le Massa qui est
le marché des arts et du spectacle
d'Abidjan et c'est l'un des seuls
marchés dans le monde dans lequel il y a
une discipline slam nous sommes heureux
de constater aujourd'hui que nous
croisons les jeunes qui sont sur la
scène avoir des mimiques qui rappellent
une slameuse tout comme Michael Jackson
m'avait impacté un jour aujourd'hui j'ai
droit à même hier j'ai reçu un message
d'une jeune fille qui dit que je veux
être comme toi
nous sommes heureux de ce parcours qui
est toujours en cours d'ailleurs et
personnellement
je suis heureuse aujourd'hui de
rencontrer toutes ces jeunesse qui
s'intéressent aux slam heureuse de
n'avoir pas perdu les repères que mon
frère mon père et ma mère depuis les
débuts donc un environnement de
créativité multiple l'amour pour les
lettres la résilience
et aujourd'hui je suis heureuse d'avoir
glané autant de prix que possible bon
c'est pas énorme c'est juste sept on
espère qu'on aura des grammes bientôt
et je suis heureuse de faire partie de
ces membres donc les 21 membres sur les
5 continents du comité artistique
international du Massa et c'est une
nouvelle que j'ai eu il y a à peine
quelques semaines je suis là toute jeune
du lot et c'est un grand honneur pour
moi de faire partie de ce comité et ça
c'est le signe que notre chemin se
déroule comme il se doit et j'ai les
pieds nus vous avez remarqué c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs quand je suis
en performance c'est pour apprécier
chaque micromètre carré du chemin avec
toutes les joies toutes les difficultés
que ça apporte et toutes les leçons
apprises pour pouvoir impacter
l'histoire où est-ce que je vais faire
partie de ces personnes que le monde
s'empressera d'effacer des mémoire
toutes les questions de choix et moi
pour ma part le slam m'a choisi pour
être peut-être
un modèle d'enfuir je vous remercie
c'était ami
[Applaudissements]